en otros vídeos nos presentaron la idea
de la curva de densidad que es un
resumen de la distribución de datos y en
el futuro veremos cosas como densidad de
probabilidad pero lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo será deducir las
propiedades que nos permiten describir
estas curvas de densidad y las
distribuciones que representan aquí
tenemos cuatro curvas y en lo primero
que quiero que pensemos es si podemos
aproximar el valor de en medio la
mediana para el conjunto de datos
descrito por estas curvas de densidad
recordemos que tenemos un conjunto de
números y los ordenamos de menor a mayor
la mediana será el valor de en medio o
el valor intermedio entre dos valores en
un caso como éste queremos encontrar el
valor para el cual la mitad de los datos
están por encima de este valor y la otra
mitad de los datos están por debajo de
este valor al ver una curva de densidad
nos interesa el área bajo la curva y
queremos encontrar el valor para el cual
tengamos la misma área por arriba de
este valor y la misma área por debajo de
ese valor y con solo verlo podríamos
decir que este es el valor de en medio
la mediana en general si tenemos una
distribución simétrica como ésta la
mediana estará justo a lo largo de la
línea de simetría aquí tenemos una
distribución un poco más inusual a la
cual le llamamos distribución bimodal
tenemos dos prominencias principales
aquí pero es simétrica y el punto de
simetría se encuentra justo aquí por lo
que este valor nuevamente será la
mediana otra forma de pensar en esto es
ver que el área a la izquierda de este
valor es igual al área que está a la
derecha de este valor y esto lo hace ser
la mediana que pasa cuando tenemos
distribuciones no simétricas queremos
usar el mismo principio queremos
encontrar el valor para el cual el área
a la derecha de ese valor sea la misma
que el área a la izquierda de ese valor
nuevamente en estos ejemplos no seremos
muy exactos pero trataremos de
aproximarnos quizás se sientan tentados
de elegir el punto más alto de la curva
como lo hago aquí pero es evidente que
el área a la derecha es más grande que
el área a la izquierda así que este
valor no es
mediana si pongo la mediana un poco más
hacia la derecha más o menos por acá se
aproxima mucho más al valor de la
mediana real es razonable decir que el
área de aquí es muy parecida al área de
acá y si este es el caso entonces este
valor será la mediana de forma similar
para esta curva de aquí quizá la mediana
se encuentra por acá nuevamente esto es
sólo una aproximación y parece muy
razonable afirmar que estas dos áreas
son iguales aunque ésta es más larga es
mucho más delgada y aunque esta parte de
la curva es más alta es mucho más corta
así pues la mediana para las curvas de
distribución bien portadas como éstas
será el valor para el cual el área a la
izquierda del valor es igual al área a
la derecha de ese valor y que hay de la
media para encontrar la media tomamos
todos los posibles valores y los
ponderamos por la frecuencia con la que
aparecen y sumamos todo para
distribuciones simétricas la mediana y
la media van a ser iguales esa también
será la media y esta otra también si
queremos pensar en esto en términos de
la física en la media sería nuestro
punto de balance o el punto en el que
queremos poner un fulcro para poder
balancear la distribución si colocamos
aquí fulcro podemos imaginar que la
distribución se va a poder balancear y
todo viene de esta idea de la
ponderación del promedio de todos los
valores posibles y cuál será la media
para estas distribuciones asimétricas
veamos esta distribución en donde
deberíamos poner el fulcro para que esto
pudiera balancearse que nos dice nuestra
intuición tenemos áreas iguales en ambos
lados pero al tener
esta larga cola a la derecha va a jalar
la media hacia la derecha de la mediana
en este caso por lo que nuestro punto de
balance va a estar más cercano a este
lugar de nuevo les recuerdo que todas
estas son sólo aproximaciones aquí
estaría aproximadamente nuestra media
que en este caso está a la derecha de la
mediana aquí está la mediana y aquí la
media en este otro caso como tengo esta
larga cola hacia la izquierda para poder
balancear la tengo que poner mi fulcro
por aquí la media sería aproximadamente
este valor de acá existe un término para
estas distribuciones no simétricas en
donde la media tiene un valor diferente
al de la mediana nos referimos a
distribuciones como éstas como
asimétricas a esta distribución en donde
tenemos la media a la derecha de la
mediana y esta larga cola a la derecha
se le llama asimétrica a la derecha
la idea técnica de lo asimétrico puede
complicarse bastante pero de forma
general podemos identificarla cuando t
una cola larga en una dirección esa será
la dirección de lo asimétrico o si la
media está en esa dirección a partir de
la mediana si la media está a la derecha
de la mediana por lo general tendremos
una distribución asimétrica a la derecha
aquí tenemos lo opuesto si la media está
a la izquierda de la mediana y tenemos
esta larga cola a la izquierda de
nuestra distribución por lo general a
estas distribuciones las denominamos
distribuciones asimétricas a la
izquierda